hola bienvenidos a esta nueva emisión de
reporteros aquí en france24 cierro
blanco como siempre un gusto
acompañarlos el equipo de reporteros de
france 24 se integró con las fuerzas
especiales de níger en este epicentro
del yihadismo de áfrica occidental- las
franquicias locales del grupo estado
islámico y al qaeda están compitiendo
para establecer un vasto califato en la
región del sahel los aldeanos locales
están atrapados en el fuego cruzado
temerosos que los yihadistas puedan
infiltrarse en la población y bien con
miedo a represalias unos 4000 civiles
murieron en esta zona en 2019 por lo que
el gobierno de níger tiene dos objetivos
el primero mantener a las personas a
salvo y el segundo recuperar territorios
para evitar que el califato resurja de
sus cenizas en el continente africano
veamos el siguiente reporteros
[Música]
mich el fin de la temporada de lluvias
un dique acaba de romperse unos
kilómetros río arriba en la vecina mal y
la carretera del noroeste y los
alrededores de miami la capital están
sumergido
[Música]
ya dije de cariño
la escolta de armada obligatoria tan
pronto como salimos de la ciudad es
rápidamente reforzada por un convoy de
las fuerzas especiales nigerianas nos
dirigimos a la región de abalá en la
provincia de tillaberi en el sur burkina
faso en el norte mal y toda la zona se
encuentra en estado de emergencia
llegamos a uno de los epicentros del
yihadismo en áfrica occidental
aquí las franquicias del autodenominado
grupo estado islámico y de al qaeda
compiten por el proyecto del
atendimiento de un vasto califato en el
sahel
nos dijeron que cada jueves de vez en
cuando hay un motociclista que viene por
allí así que vamos a ir a comprobarlo
las motocicletas están prohibidas en
cuanto nos hablan de una motocicleta
seguro que son terroristas porque cada
vez que las pasamos llevan la pistola al
hombro
a la cabeza del convoy y capitán así se
conoce bien el desierto desde hace meses
él y sus soldados escogidos a dedo han
estado recorriendo esta zona gris en la
frontera de mali
donde la franquicia sahel jana del grupo
estado islámico está en auge
primer pueblo
a veces no lo sabemos tal vez haya
infiltrados en la población
por lo que podría haber represalias
contra ellos así que tratamos de
proteger a la gente buena que está
dispuesta a darnos información valiosa
tratamos de contar
cada vez
[Música]
deberías mirar en las latas y no es
combustible
tal vez están usando motocicletas
escondidas
normalmente cuando vienen es para
repostar o hacer cosas así la frontera
es bastante grande así que probablemente
usan motos para ser mucho más rápidos
para entrar y salir rápidamente como los
ladrones
has visto alguna gente moto en los
últimos días en el pueblo húngaro nunca
qué tipo de moto nadie ha venido en moto
al pueblo dios él puede verlo yo no
puedo sabemos que un hombre llamado
traoré está en la zona
oímos que va a la mezquita de su pueblo
todas las noches sospechamos que es el
líder de los yihadistas de la zona
no más allá
no no lo sé
atrapados en el fuego cruzado estos
aldeanos están pagando el precio más
alto por el conflicto solo en 2019
murieron en esta zona 4000 civiles
no sé si fue una bala del ejército de
níger o una bala islamista la que me
alcanzó nunca sabré quién me disparó
estaba en mi campus machacando mi hijo
cuando empezó el tiroteo
solo dios sabe de dónde vino la bala
[Música]
para nada
mismo país pero diferente frente
acompañamos a mohamed bazoum señor
seguridad en níger ex ministro del
interior y candidato a la campaña para
las elecciones presidenciales de 2020 en
la frontera con nigeria
si nos ofrecemos a recibir refugiados
garantizamos su seguridad en esta zona
en nuestra frontera existe la presencia
de grupos armados muy peligrosos
esto es una prueba de que tenemos un
control total de la situación
garantizado por una presencia constante
de nuestras fuerzas de defensa y
seguridad interior no en armas
toda esta vasta región es el bastión de
la secta islámica de boko haram que
prometió lealtad al estado islámico en
[Música]
[Aplausos]
seré
embarcados en un convoy electoral
sobreprotegido seguimos al candidato
azul que vino aquí sobre todo para
marcar la presencia del estado a pocos
kilómetros de nigeria
[Música]
y la paz que retornó a la región es
gracias a nosotros al gobierno a nuestra
política y a nuestro duro trabajo para
protegerlos
somos un pequeño país rodeado de vecinos
inestables con fronteras que deben ser
aseguradas
tengan la certeza de que tenemos
suficientes reservas de armas para
mejorar la seguridad si es necesario
[Música]
un nuevo día está amaneciendo en la base
de wallaby es aquí donde se lanzó la
operación al mayor operación torbellino
una nueva ofensiva liderada por las
fuerzas especiales antiterroristas con
un solo dogma la reconquista de
territorios
hemos participado en la operación alma
house desde enero operamos solos solo
contamos con el apoyo de nuestros socios
en términos de apoyo aéreo pero por lo
demás en tierra nosotros especialmente
en nuestra unidad siempre hemos operado
solos
[Música]
los asesores del ejército de eeuu y los
miembros de la coalición internacional
son claramente visibles aquí nuevos
métodos nuevos equipos las unidades de
élite de la base igualan ya han
participado en una multitud de
operaciones sobre el terreno este año
[Música]
tarde
en el objeto que les deniega
a mí
como yo estaba
estaba entregada el humo al soporte
inicial
inshallah si dios quiere un día de la
reconquista pero la región del sahel
cubre un verdadero continente desde el
atlántico hasta el marrón cinco millones
de kilómetros cuadrados para controlar
esa es también la escala de la misión de
los ejércitos de mali burkina faso y
níger los países más afectados por la
violencia
con la unidad del teniente wahari
entramos a un pueblo cercano a la zona
de las tres fronteras la región de todos
los peligros del sahel
hola miguel y soy militar soy del
volante estoy aquí para ayudarlos
ese día el oficial médico del grupo
experimento una táctica completamente
nueva
ah
trajimos mucha medicina para tratar a la
gente del pueblo
los software bocata para julián para
mejorar por m
johan que digo me voy para él
wang jing wang gang
[Música]
y rabo
donde no somos todos iguales ya sea que
vengamos de tal o tal pueblo
debemos estar unidos compartir las
mismas cosas trajimos medicinas
especialmente para los niños de y azúcar
y energía se organizará la repartición
tuvieron un café activado como amado y
no favorezcan música
a pesar del entusiasmo general todos lo
saben perfectamente en una hora los
soldados y sus tanques se habrán ido y
muy lejos de aquí trajimos herramientas
medios que necesitan bienes que
necesitan así que va a crear un sentido
de gratitud les estamos dando ayuda sin
esperar nada a cambio
así que ya ve esto es una ilustración de
lo que estoy diciendo
lo que están diciendo en el idioma local
están diciendo muchas gracias que dios
nos recompense
[Música]
nuestra misión a bordo de unos días con
las fuerzas nigerianas está a punto de
terminar
como una aparición se divisa un convoy
francés de la fuerza marcan a un convoy
que parece interminable sin fin como
podría ser el compromiso de miles de
franceses en el sahel
a menos que la colisión se rinda las
fuerzas locales serán abandonadas a su
suerte de la noche a la mañana
pero para los espectadores víctimas en
la primera línea del conflicto no
importa si son muy guapos es como un
desfile militar solo para nosotras
y admiramos a los soldados franceses
tanto como a los nuestros
[Música]
se estima que el número de islamistas
africanos es de 15000
lo que la convierte en la mayor fuerza
yihadista del planeta
una fuerza que ya se está expandiendo de
varias formas mucho más allá del sahel
desde costa de marfil hasta mozart bit
el sueño de muerte del califato mundial
cobra vida en el continente africano
no no
[Música]
[Aplausos]
de lesiones
[Música]
hasta aquí esta emisión de reporteros en
france24 recuerde que se le gustó el
reportaje puede ver nuevamente a través
de nuestra página web france24 puntocom
hasta una próxima oportunidad
[Música]